the International Space Station could
soon operate without a crew for the
first time in nearly two decades
it comes after yesterday's dramatic
Soyuz launch failure over Kazakhstan the
capsule hurtled back to earth from 31
miles up and made an emergency landing
the two crew members astronaut Nick
Hague and cosmonaut Alexei ovchinin are
okay this morning Russia suspended man
Soyuz flights while it investigates mark
Strassmann is at the Kennedy Space
Center in Florida with how that puts all
US manned missions on hold mark good
morning good morning and that is why
this Russian failure really matters the
Soyuz Rockets are grounded no more
flights until they figure out what went
wrong yesterday and for America the
Soyuz is the only taxi right now that we
have to head to the space station and
there is liftoff two minutes into a
six-hour flight to the International
Space Station
the crew of two aboard the Soyuz rocket
knew something was wrong their capsule
shook and they felt a sudden
weightlessness you can see the moment a
rocket malfunction triggered an
automatic abort system separating the
capsule and sending it into ballistic
descent parachutes guided them down
roughly 250 miles from the launch site
crew members Nick Hague and alexey
ovchinin looked unharmed and grateful to
be alive the crews were all ready
everybody was prepared and this is what
they trained for this is what they
prepare for the Russian rocket failure
comes at a crossroads for American space
travel and the final liftoff of
discovery seven years ago the space
shuttle fleet was retired
and ever since nasa has paid the
russians roughly eighty million dollars
a seat to fly its astronauts to the
space station two American companies
SpaceX and Boeing are developing new
spaceships to fly NASA's astronauts both
hope to begin launching crewed flights
next summer but there's deadline
pressure America's Soyuz contracts with
the Russians end next July do you feel
under the gun now to make it happen
schedule pressure is never going to get
in the way of making sure we have a safe
vehicle fine you want to get it right
have to this is the upper dome John
Mulholland oversees the development of
Boeing Starliner earlier this week he
gave us a tour of the spacecraft
assembly plant in Florida it's important
the world sees Americans putting
Americans into space absolutely and if
you look at the International Space
Station 100 billion dollar orbiting
laboratory that has science capability
that you cannot give here on earth and
so fully utilizing that capability in
the next 10 15 20 years it's going to be
incredibly important there are three
people on the space station right now
and the issues with the Soyuz rocket
does not affect them they have enough
supplies and they also have a Soyuz
capsule docked to the station to bring
them back to earth in December and
beyond that has to be a relief if you're
up there yeah knowing how much longer
they would have to stay because of that
crash but it is incredible to see those
astronauts walk out of that capsule
unharmed right especially after what
they apparently went through which is
coming down six times the rate of
gravity so that's tough and then they
were spinning - yeah so and and working
with the Russians despite how bitter
relations have been this one project has
United us for for so many years now
hopefully they can get it up and running
sooner yeah I mean anybody who watch
that live feed thought oh man what's
going on and to know that they're okay
whew their family was hugging them extra
high yesterday